we've got starting here Daniel Sain who
runs socialite which is an agency that
helps brands navigate the space and find
the right bloggers to work with then we
have Eric who is from united talent
agencies it's going to be talking about
social media as it pertains to
celebrities and then another Eric double
Eric's eric is the men's guru over at
Saks and we're both wearing j.lindeberg
suits so that's something else to note I
think watching its acts right then we
have Christine bender who is an SVP over
at Armani Exchange and lastly andrew
schmidt from puma who is not only a good
friend but is taking me on a variety of
trips with Puma so he's going to be
talking a bit about what they're doing
so let's start off and do a question for
everyone and so first you know everyone
here has done work with bloggers in the
past and so I think if we can just start
off and say what you guys look for it
your brand's when you are working with a
blogger and how you make that decision
maybe Daniel kick it off and what do you
think sure before obviously sitting
starting socialite we where i worked
with rebecca minkoff and really kind of
work with that Bryant to establish you
know what that brands voice was how do
we establish it how we build it how we
use bloggers to kind of increase that
brand message and what we learned or
what I learned from my years there was
really finding the right publishers
everything so for us in our approach for
all the brands that we work with now
it's more about who is the right face
who's right publisher but also what are
the analytics behind them are they
selling product what type of product are
they selling and knowing that
information is what really helps us
choose the best publishers Andrew you've
worked with you know on just on the
trips which obviously I've I've been a
part of you've worked with people who
are really big and really small so our
analytics as important for Puma yeah for
sure I mean I think you want to kind of
take into consideration what the goal
for the brand is
brand awareness or if you're actually
trying to influence and drive sales with
the trips that we went on for instance
it was more about brand awareness so
Puma had a 70 foot sailboat that was
racing around the world stopping in 10
ports and so the idea behind that was to
kind of bring people with different
perspectives that had a different reach
that might be able to kind of tap into a
demographic that was interested in
sailing or potentially interested in
sailing and through the different
perspectives that was kind of the goal
so there wasn't really trying to drive
sales necessarily but more about brand
awareness and to kind of get the word
out I think when you when you do come
from a retail when you have a retail
objectives it is important to align
yourself with bloggers that enhance your
brand enhance your message but again
have has this has that proven track
record of driving sales because at the
end of the day that's that's you know
the ultimate testament of how healthy
your brand is are people buying your
product and I think bloggers are an
important tactic to leverage because
they do give an authenticity to your
brand that you might not be able to
convey on your own they're able you're
they allow you to engage with your
customer in a much more intimate
personal way and it does give you an
opportunity to again reach and scale in
a way that you wouldn't be able to do in
your own channels and I and I think to
jump in on that I would say all the time
don't use technology for technology's
sake use it to really drive your
business goal forward right and so to
look at the premise of your question do
you need to reach out to a blogger do
you need a blogger outreach strategy and
if so why and how do you and what is the
business goal at the end of that is it
to get publicity and buzz well then it's
a different set of bloggers is it to get
social awareness well then maybe you
need bloggers that have huge Klout
scores right to so you sort of have to
look at the objective of what you're
trying to do and then look at the
strategy kind of around that we're in a
unique situation because sax is a brand
that carries a lot of brands
hundreds thousands of brands so we need
how many brands are you wearing now I
rang a few but no good we're looking for
bloggers that also talk about the big
brands because those are the tends to be
the the reasons why our customer comes
into the store because we have the big
brands but when we launch new brands
we're looking for a very different type
of bloggers who's speaking about those
unique niche type of products and we've
had success when we picked up new lines
that this customer who comes into our
store doesn't is not aware of but yet
the bloggers are blogging about it so
what we've had to do was actually shift
inventory from the store where it's not
selling as well to the website because
there's a younger hipper customer
listening to those younger cooler
bloggers and so we actually have a need
for both that's interesting i think you
know to kind of expand on that nut
bloggers have been used thinking a lot
of ways brands are kind of dipped their
foot into the pool you know and they're
kind of just putting their toe in and
seeing is this something that we want to
do you know you're not seeing bloggers
yet fronting Revlon campaigns or on the
covers of magazines and so something I'm
interested in hearing what you guys have
to think is do you think that bloggers
have enough mass appeal to do that are
they going to be the next spokespeople
in a bigger way are they going to
continue to replace celebrities or are
they just finding their place in the
market which is somewhere in the middle
they're not quite a celebrity but they
obviously have a lot of pole in the
industry well I would say that you know
we're definitely are seeing the
celebrity bloggers we definitely see
those personalities who stand out and
you really pay attention to the blind
boys the man repellers you know
individuals who are able to really have
a large audience and really speak to
that audience for the collective greater
you know for all those kind of rising
for all those who are not at that level
I think it comes more into play you know
how does that person integrate into the
brand but also how do those individuals
become brands how do those individuals
sell their own product how do those
individuals kind of take that audience
that they're using to you know create
hundreds thousands millions of sales to
then say to themselves well I can get a
higher amount if I have my own
collection I can have a higher amount of
that affiliate if I'm able to develop my
own line
so I think it's more about there is no
right answer in terms of what a blogger
can accomplish it really does become
about that individual and what
opportunities are presented them to
allow them to get to that place but I
think we're going to see more bloggers
developing lines more bloggers fronting
collections more bloggers on the covers
of publications I think Kate Upton is a
great example of someone who grew
through viral success she wasn't a
blogger but a YouTube videos what got
around to the cover of Vanity Fair onto
the cover of bogan onto the cover of
Elle we're gonna see more of those
discoveries coming from digital niche is
the new mass right and if you are a
niche player and have a hundred thousand
Twitter followers per se and a few very
you know loyal email list and a
readership you can launch as you said
you can get onto the cover of Vanity
Fair right and so I the morn ish you are
and the more loyalty you have in many
ways the bigger you are right now well
if you're saying niche is the new mass
then do you think that actually the
whole system is going to change that
it's not going to be as important to get
on the cover or to be that spokesperson
but that you can be the kate upton of
your niche market you can be the person
in that small space and our brand is
going to just take the spend that they
would usually say that beauty and now
instead of just beauty it's 15 things
across beauty and each one has a
different solution as we and as we dive
down and get and get be sure and knee
sure right the analytics and the
statistics and and the exactly who
you're targeting will be able to be more
effective for the brands and speaking of
that of media spends and advertising
budgets you know someone like puma right
probably has the largest budget up on
this stage as far as marketing goes and
so social is a drop in that bucket and
and how do you you know how are you guys
doing that and are you seeing it growing
and what do you think needs to happen to
make that grow more quickly if that
makes sense you want me to really yeah
again social it has a social budget
growing yeah i mean has a social budget
going and what is stopping it from from
more how what is what needs to happen in
the marketplace for for Puma to shift
more dollars into social I mean I think
it's it's just a it's the market
conditions it's aware way things are
going you know two years ago you kind of
had to push people to put things online
or to really dedicate time and energy to
it and now every Regional Marketing
Manager that we work with is saying like
digital's coming first so when there's
kind of a change within the company then
that money kind of starts getting
allocated towards us so yeah I mean our
budget has grown lockstep I would say
with the market and where it gets
allocated depends on what the campaign
is we use an agency that does most of
our online spend but we do have kind of
a little nest egg that we can activate
on and put towards certain things that
we feel need it and I'm interested to
hear in a physical space with Armani
Exchange insects what you guys are doing
to kind of bring things you're learning
and digital into that physical space and
if there are things that you're able to
do that you weren't able to do two or
three years ago I think technology in
the store has to provide utility like
obviously there's an entertainment
factor but I think that that Wayne's
once the novelty wears off and what's
the purpose of technology on store so
we're definitely exploring what that
role is I think it has to be scalable
because when you think about a specialty
brand like Armani Exchange and the
presence that we do have like we are
serving quite a large customer so we
want as many people to be able to engage
with what we have for them in store so
NFC for instance is something that has
been top of mind and you know with the
latest iteration of the iphone which
would have we're supposed to have NFC
technology that's something that I think
would help unlock that type of
integration store I think you have to be
very careful though you don't want to
just distract the customer from the
shopping experience you want to enhance
it you want to help them make that two
zishan to purchase again it's all about
driving that trafficked into conversion
so any tactics that we leverage have to
support that greater good you know where
we're all we all touch different areas
of the business about the end of the day
you know I sell clothes so I have to I
remember that every day every time I
walk into the office so it's important
to just no matter what you're leveraging
it's it's it's serving that on purpose
well in terms of technology I think
every associate at our store in New York
City has an ipad so they're using that
ipad to leverage the inventory that we
have on our website conjunction with the
inventory in the store if it's a size
not available in the store they can go
to the ipad see what's on the website
and then ship it directly to the
customer so again it's using technology
with weave client omni-channel i'm sure
that i don't think it's a word I've
heard yet today but definitely omni so
that we can have one consistent message
whether it's on the website but there's
at the store and then using Instagram
and the iPad and things like that to
sell it wherever it may be whether it's
at the warehouse whether it's for the
website and whether it's in the store go
ahead I mean I would say we definitely
seen an increase in budget and what
brands are spending on the blogosphere
what they're investing in that
development of content I think a lot of
wrens are realize that yes you can do
social media but when you have to fill
those channels with a constant you know
24 hour news cycle of content and
conversations it's very difficult to do
that without influencers without
bloggers without activating them so
we're starting to see them realize that
if they want to have success in social
media they need to work with bloggers
it's not and also it's more of a need
and because of that the budgets have
increased some we started socialite you
know we were getting brand saying well
we have a hundred dollars for a
placement now we're seeing brands for
like we have a hundred thousand dollars
to actually make something happen and
that's where it's getting more
intelligent that's where it's getting
more in depth that's where the contents
spreading across an entire year and
really developing these smart campaigns
that look beyond just what you're doing
in social but also how are you feeling
those channels what is the content
that's on there is that content sellable
and is that influence are also selling
and returning that customer back to your
online store those are the things that
get us excited about the space can I can
I talk about it just for a second I
think the
cross section or there where the two
intersect of the physical and the
digital spaces right now is the most
exciting thing about this space right
now because you know ten years ago
everyone thought the internet was gonna
kill the physical place right amazon was
going to destroy barnes and noble right
then we went into this period where okay
well maybe maybe now the two can sort of
live together but but sort of separately
now thanks to smartphones and mobile and
ipads and so forth the digital space and
the physical space working together
right the fact that you pull out your
phone and get new to call an uber the
fact that you're a retailer and should
have data every time that somebody walks
into your store that space right now is
only beginning to be explored and i
think will will explode but i think is
so exciting and sort of how technology
can help the physical place and how the
physical place can help the technology
and I think it's I'm really excited to
actually see that grow and I'll just say
one other thing in terms of using the
bloggers in the digital space to get
people into the store again when we've
had events when we've had fashions night
out when we launched a new brand and
were able to tap into the right bloggers
we're seeing people that would never
have normally stepped us foot into sacks
with Avenue come in so we're seeing a
whole new demographic I've younger
people coming into sacks like oh wow I
didn't know you had this I didn't know
you I didn't know you had this line so
it's games completely changed the events
in the physical store because we are
reaching out to these influencers in the
digital realm yeah and I think what he's
saying really does speak to the idea of
the personal celebrity you know we've
kind of seen celebrities really rise up
and celebrities are still extremely
important in terms of power selling but
now you have these individual
influencers who speak to that audience
and who are really really great at
saying by this come here meet me and
having that personal relationship with
someone and having a relationship that
isn't really established in the
celebrity world because there is that
wall is really kind of what's bringing
so many bloggers to the table really
bringing so many influencers to the
forefront as to marketing campaigns and
how we develop those question for you
eric is that you know I think
traditional celebrities survived for so
long on a lack of access
and mystery right I mean you're we love
celebrities because they're mysterious
they're not like us and there's been a
lot of very public and famous trip ups
when celebrities are starting to do
social and now there's all this access
all the time and you know coming from a
talent agency that's managing these very
you know people who are very they're out
there everyone sees them what are you
doing to help that like how are you
managing celebrities in this new world
and what is that doing to the idea of
what celebrity is so I think the
foundation I say is that we've we've
crossed the Rubicon the toothpaste is
out of the to write your people want
their celebrities to be obtainable now
right that's what the people expect
that's what the audience's now expect
and if a celebrity or if a client of
mine is not on social media in any sort
of form whether it's Instagram or
Twitter or Facebook you know a lot of
clients are now doing reddit AMA s right
ask me anything right the premise of
that alone says says everything right
that these celebrities are now putting
themselves out there to have a dialogue
with their fans and I think it makes
them stronger I think it makes the
connection stronger I think it makes
them as a brand stronger and so don't
expect that to go away as my practice
crisis get more and more and the people
who aren't there the people who aren't
on those platforms are beginning to lose
opportunities they are beginning to not
see their power in the same way or their
influence and reach in the same way and
and so we're there I mean you just have
like it or not that's that's sort of
where we are right now because that's
what the audience wants I think the same
thing you know I'd like to hear what
it's doing to brands you know you know
Eric you've talked about how you think
men style blogs have done a lot to
demystify you know in demystify this
space and so how did brands engage in
social media and tell these stories all
the time and continue to keep a
consistent message and also keep some
shred of mystery and well there's
there's a celebrity blogger and
influencer and then there's the street
style blogger and influencer and what we
find is that in like deal with the men's
area is
the men respond to these street style
bloggers because that's what demystifies
fashion I think that's what guys are
looking for they're looking for answers
or I think with the women shoppers they
love the glamour the sex appeal of the
celebrity but our men's customer they
love the distort of this authentic
street style influenced and so again is
kind of what's the difference between
men and women which where do you tap
into who are you looking for so again we
found great success with the street
style bloggers and influencers and
partnering with them I think how we're
approaching fall for instance and and
denim is the big focus for us I'm
wearing a pair right now shameless
shameless plug but how how we're
messaging our denim to women is very
different than how we're messaging it to
men women shop men by so our our
approach has been much more directional
with women and much more sorry
inspiration with women much more
directional with Matt because we can be
more forthright they men like to know
what to buy and seek that guidance so
who we've partnered with it definitely
has that credibility in the men's space
so we've been very careful to make sure
that we've we've crafted our stories um
specifically for for men and women so
they resonate better and you know
they're still driving towards that same
strategy that we've sat so I think it's
important to make sure rather than have
a blogger strategy or a facebook
strategy or a social strategy or what
have you it's really what is that what
are those business objectives that
you're driving and how all how do all
these channels further that goal for it
for you and that's how you maintain
consistency wherever you are can I ask
you a question yeah how do you guys
define a blogger right because if I walk
into your store and I have a good or a
bad experience and I tweet and Facebook
about it am i a blogger all of a sudden
or is it or is it just someone who
actually has a www something so I think
that's a I think that's a great question
so i think we treat everybody like
customers first and foremost your
customer if you post on our Facebook
we're going to reach out to you because
we want to understand why you had a
great experience or why he had a bad
experience we want to change that if
you're a blogger you know
I think we're all I think because of
social media we've all become brands we
all have audiences whether we have our
own tumblr page we just have a facebook
presence or we just have an Instagram
presence we are all brands and we all
have an audience that follow us that we
have some sort of obligation to write
like we know how it feels when we post
something and all her friends like it
that it's and we want to continue that
feeling so I think with bloggers it's
it's a term for me its scalability what
they stand for what presents that they
have how do they leverage and at the end
of the day are they moving product blah
I think a blogger is is a marketer and
helps brands adapt their voice to a
specific customer to you know achieve a
certain business objective so again it's
how I think you it's how you interact
and how you and and what your presence
is yeah and for us I mean we don't
really even call our talents bloggers we
call them socialites it really is about
someone who has that influence who can
actually move that crowd who can move
that needle and we look at specific
things within the members that we
represent to really reflect that so they
have to have about 50,000 social
followers they have to be someone who is
the face of the brand they have to be
someone who visually is appealing they
have to be someone who their site their
aesthetic the look the feel it is what
the industry is looking for and I think
you know what we're starting to see is
yes blogger is a very general term there
are millions of bloggers you know there
are millions people and they're not that
important there is a select group of
people who are extremely important and
that's what we look for that's that's a
socialite so continuing that I'm how do
you guys as Prince make sure you're
working with the right person like to
your point there are I think 135 million
blogs and you know there's probably 20
percent of that is fashion so I'm not a
math guy but that seems like a lot of
fashion blogs out there and so you know
are you using what services are you
using to find are using agencies to find
people are you just using social teams
how do you find the right people to work
with
so when you when you work internally at
a brand I think you know you have a
point of view on who you should be
working with and it's it's very
important to you know have that strong
identity and know who those the right
affiliations are so I think it
definitely comes from from our team we
define who who best portrays what the
power brand stands for and who will
translate it in the way that pushes
pushes our boundaries comfortably I
think with digital especially when when
you are a heritage brand you know it's
been we retail companies have been slow
to adapt digital because it requires a
relinquish enough control like you open
yourself up to interpretation and rather
than kind of shy away from it you have
to embrace it but you have to do it with
with trusted partner so I think first
and foremost like that's what we we look
for with with the people that we partner
with like do we trust that they will
interpret the our brand in the way that
you know honors our heritage but also
you know helps us you know chart new
territory and we work with so many
brands and that is the biggest challenge
is to let these big brands relinquish
control right to get dirty we was
talking earlier you know talking about
getting a little bit dirty and a lot of
these brands just don't want to let
themselves get dirty but you kind of
have to at a certain point and even a
sec we have to sometimes relinquish
control and let the digital space just
do what it does and and and respond to
it have to be can write it's absolutely
it's a missed opportunity most much like
your celebrities like it's wild there is
this arif mysticism that has worked in
the past there's been you know everyone
wants more and when when a customer
chooses to follow you online they are
looking for that deeper relationship
they want to look behind the curtain
they want to know what's happening so
again like we we have to think about it
in a different way like that interaction
has to be extraordinarily personal but
that's how you that's how you cultivate
loyalty with your with your customer
with your audience and Andrew I mean for
things that you've done with the Puma
how did you when you put those groups
together you said they
you were looking for people that kind of
touched on different points what was was
the ability to story tell was that what
was the difference-maker and who you
picked more than the following yeah I
mean obviously the following plays into
it you want to have that message you go
out to as many people as you can it's
not just your not just bring someone
along for the ride because like they
post a couple of nice photos but um it
depends on what it is you know like for
the lifestyle stuff it's a little bit
different than what we do for the
performance stuff and there's always
different stories going on for you knows
is it soccer is it running or is it just
kind of like sneaker culture so to find
the people in those spaces that do have
an influence is difficult we use kind of
a variety of different things a lot of
it comes from internal you know people
just sending links around and blogs and
saying check this person out there a
good fit for the brand you know we've
used for card we've used agencies it
just it's kind of a conglomeration of
everything I think maybe for a last
question it's here if you know if there
are bloggers and there's a lot of
bloggers here today what they can do to
better position themselves to work with
brands and also if you're getting
pitched a lot it's something I've
whenever I take meetings with brands i
always ask them how much they're getting
pitched by bloggers and i am astonished
by how many say they're getting zero
pitches a week bloggers aren't emailing
them full fully thought out ideas and so
if that's your experience and and and
what your advice is to those those
people who are looking to work with you
i would say for influencers who really
want to be a part of the fashion
industry is understand where you fit
within the industry it's not always
about the face it's about the editor
it's about the creative i it's about the
photographer realize that there's more
opportunities and really being a piece
of the cog of what makes a shoot
successful or a piece of a cog of what
makes a campaign successful and really
focusing on those talents also you know
think of yourself and think about your
blog as a resume it's a business card
it's
you know what have you succeeded at what
have you done before in the past which
brand associations you have which press
hits have you received things like that
become very very important for brands as
they're making decisions also I mean
selfless plug like work with an agency
it's you know more of its becoming more
more or less and less we're seeing
brands reach out directly to influencers
they're going to agencies just to find
out who to work with they're using you
know applications like for car they're
using groups like us to really find out
who to work with associate with that
connect to it I think there's you know
fair practices in that and I think
there's a way for you to grow by just
really paying attention to what your
agent can do for you and what your
manager can do for you I think you need
a clear point of view that's
differentiated because like I think
we've mentioned a couple of times there
are so many bloggers why are you
different than everybody else I think
it's important to just have a clear idea
of what you stand for and make sure that
it's consistent because i think what
brands are looking for again is that
that understanding of how you're going
to interpret them in your in your own
way and make sure that it does it does
enhance their identity and i think
looking across platforms right is is
what is your presence as a blogger on
youtube do you have a presence on
youtube what is your presence on vine
what is your presence on the Instagram
right and and how can a story that I can
pitch to you as a blogger how can I have
different components of it that can live
in different parts of your social graph
and I think that's really important as
well it's no longer just this
old-fashioned thing called a website
it's now the entire package and what is
the entire social graph and reach look
like I also think you know if you have a
set list of brands that you are going
after that you want to work with to be
loyal and treat it as a business and be
ethical about it like you know there's
nothing more annoying and you know we do
something with one person and then like
the next week they're posting about our
competitors just the same way they do to
us and it's like you know you have to
kind of tree
if you're really trying to make it into
a business like you have to treat it
like one and you know be loyal if you
know if things change then of course
that's going to happen but i think you
know having some consistency and
standing for something instead of just
being like oh you know this person
sending me free product this week i'm
going to post about it i mean to an
extent that's cool but if you're really
like working with brands I think you
need to be pretty professional about it
or we would when I was at CNN we had to
saying that authenticity was the new
objectivity right and i think that's
always important right make sure that
your authentic and like you said right
just don't don't post them it you know
make make sure you're real and people
will set that out of here if you're not
authentic just in terms of the pitch and
me being approached or the sacks being
approached I do get pitched but I always
leave the pitch not exactly sure what it
is that they're pitching so again in
terms of those that are interested in
working with us like have a clear
message have a clear point of view
exactly what is it that you're offering
us and how does it relate to what we do
so saying I want to work views not
enough due diligence what saying I'd
like to work with you is not yeah and I
get that all the time you know I'm no
set up a meeting or coffee in it and
then it's over and I'm like hmm what
does he want she wants free clothing
we're pupas on this hand okay i think so
i think that's it for question four
questions do you guys but see if anyone
out there has any so kind of what i'm
hearing through a bunch of this as a
creative potentially pitching to one of
you guys I don't do blogging but do like
our direction for television is trying
to come up with a value proposition for
you some type of way that whatever i'm
gonna do is going to make you money
right and i feel like in the creative
industry we kind of don't like going
down that road we're scared to go it's
gonna make you a hundred thousand
dollars if you work with me you know but
that's something that we have to become
comfortable but it being a business it's
not just art you know so just I'm
following up with up
I think it is important I think to me a
great idea is one that works so as a
creative person that that is planning on
pitching for new business case studies I
think always go a long way so proving
what what you've done in the past and
how that's driven results um speaks
volumes I think you it is difficult to
forecast how successful a social you
know you I I've come from the agents if
I have an agency background I've heard
my clients always tell me I want a viral
idea we can't promise you a viral idea
we can do our best based on how we know
you know what we know our audience is
consuming online and based on some other
other programs but it's difficult to
predict how something is going to be
received so I think again hindsight is
twenty-twenty take what you've done
establish a case for it and make sure
that you've learned with learned from it
and that's what i would use when I if I
were pitching for new business and
that's what I have done when pitching
for new business also to your point you
know you do something very specific you
don't have a blog it's a good time for
those type of creatives who don't
necessarily have a presence to connect
you know there's a lot of bloggers out
there if we're looking for creatives
like you who want to work on projects
with you and it's very very easy to
enhance the quality of content across
the blogosphere by just partnering
artists with the people who have the up
face the people who have the audience so
think about it that way as well look
through the blogsphere find people who
really kind of fit within your category
and then partner up because you're going
to have a much stronger pitch you're
going to have your success your training
what you've done in your career now
attached to an influencer who speaks to
a hundred thousand million you know 10
million people anyone
we got one mine
sorry this questions for Eric
specifically although i'd be interested
in anything the rest of you have to say
about this as well start on eggs from a
multi-brand retailers point of view i
further to an example that you gave
earlier about say you're launching a new
brand and you are inviting bloggers and
things like that obviously you are
capitalizing on the cachet both of the
brand identity and the bloggers identity
whether they have mass appeal or it's a
more niche market where does the
identity of saks fit within that and how
do you maintain the sacks identity
through the lens of the brand identity
and the bloggers identity well and it's
all about brand positioning like brand
curates a lot of different brands we buy
specific things from a lot of the same
brands to our competitors do so again we
have to kind of create our own identity
in our own point of view and then look
for partners influencers bloggers that
are in line with our overall point of
view so that they can represent these
other brands in line with the way we
want them represented in our store does
that make sense so again it's always
this filtering that's filtering this
editing and this editing so you found
the right partners till you find the
right brands till you find the right
product from those brands so that gives
you a clear point of view and
differentiated point of view and then
finding those partners that could help
establish that excellent I think I think
we're up for time huh well thank you
everyone thank y'all thank y'all
you